thanks to the organizers for inviting me
Ben it's a pleasure to be here and I'm a
little humbled at the audience there's
so many experts among you and and so
many folks that I look up to as
colleagues so I welcome your feedback so
today I want to talk about how we can
use the results of a lot of the
high-throughput data coming out on
cancer genomes to ultimately have a have
a genetic wiring model for patients for
the individual patient tumors so we can
use those to think about how to target
them and the first thing that and I
guess the the the angle I want to take
is to think about this sort of match and
then extend idea right so we want to we
want to leverage the the trove of data
we have on lots of patients to think
about what what is you know this new
patient that comes into the clinic
what's the the most similar type of
cancer we've seen at this point and then
not ignore the specific nuances we see
in that tumor and sort of fit the wiring
diagram to that patient's tumor once we
know sort of the class of tumors it
belongs to right we want to use the
statistical power of the many to
informed the even even the one case here
that's sort of the angle and so there's
two parts to this this brief talk first
we have to delineate the these different
subtypes of cancer the different forms
and the the rough approximation to this
is sort of these axes I'm showing here
that the new TCGA pan-cancer project
called pan can atlas is sort of taking
this angle where we think about breaking
tumors down or classifying them by the
type of process the mutagen the the
event that that that screwed things up
to begin with the external event what
kind of tissue were cell of that
was was altered you know what whatever
it was it that's the starting state that
we began with it in that's that that was
the representative normal cell and then
of course the the pathways that are
impacted by those assaults and if we can
you know put tumors on this sort of
access then you know we could maybe
address some of these important
questions about the biology and about
clinical treatment of these things and
so one I guess one way to view this
right would be suppose you had you know
drug sensitivity information or
predicted let's say you mapped your
classifiers from cell lines on to this
and could map it onto this space it'd be
awesome if we had this kind of full
picture of tumor biology we could kind
of so red here would be sensitive that
you're gonna have a response and so if
you have a particular patients we would
know for example that all that all these
different types of cells no matter what
the oncogenic process was would respond
to this particular treatment right this
would be an awesome computational model
to have in hand and then we could use
this to to match and sub two patients
tumors to and then use them to predict
treatment so how do we get a view on the
different types of cells the difference
that that are impacted by tumors and the
different types of forms that cancer
comes and we we embarked on this in TCGA
a couple years to collect all this data
across at that point twelve tumor types
to answer this question done and a lot
of different datasets to weigh in on how
these tumors samples related and so
sorry I keep flipping back and forth but
you know every every individual platform
the people that collected it kind of
clustered at their own way and then got
different groupings for the samples but
I guess the thing to appreciate is the
colors here show you the the type of
cancer and usually that's the tissue of
origin and no matter what what platform
we we court we
used including integrated platforms we
always got sort of the same answer that
the cell of origin is driving the cancer
and you could see this you know fairly
well in some of these clusters that we
built using a method that Katie Hoadley
developed called cluster of clusters
where you're just clustering that the
the memberships that you get from the
individual platforms and so we've been
and we have at UCSC we about sort of a
browser to look at these things this is
what we call the tumor map and in this
you can see the tissues color that's
what the color show you and for the most
part you know ninety percent of the
tumors kind of map with one that's like
themselves you could you couldn't you
know further inspect this map look it's
the subtypes that and so a lot of this
the subtypes have are preserved and in
these in the MRNA maps at least which is
shown here like breast cancers you can
see the different subtypes luminal 's
shown in blue or the Basil's there's
endometriosis versus serous uterine
cancers and then you know some of the
GBM subtypes are somewhat teased out by
these by these global maps and so forth
we can also make these maps out of other
types of data
besides mRNA data right if you look at
the DNA methylation data then you can
see for example in the colorectal area
you can see these hypermutated hyper and
stable tumors that lead to more
mutations due to this mismatch repaired
defect in those tumors so I guess one of
the interesting stories here that that
was at this point was for the bladder
cancers they showed this cross tumor
mapping that was happening so there was
kind of convergence and divergence so
most of the bladders were mapping on
their own here but then some were sort
of bundled with the squamous tumors and
that was a key insight because it you
know to the pathologist these did not
look like squamous tumors so the
molecular data was more sensitive
and in fact those tumors that map to the
squamous areas that's shown here versus
the bladder island one that I showed you
previously have a have a different out
different patient outcomes so this
suggests that if you know if we can take
this information and get it to the
clinics get it to the doctors hands that
they could then think about the
treatment of these patients differently
you know not like a run-of-the-mill
bladder cancer but probably something
more like what what is caused by smoking
and so forth that are that are shared
with the the squamous tumors so I hinted
that we have a new project the pan cane
Atlas and TCGA we've collected 33
different types of tumor types
there's 11,000 samples now so this is
sort of doubling the size as far as
patients go of this collection and of
course a lot more tumor types almost
triple the number and the maps now kind
of look like this so we have a lot more
sort of cross tumor connections possibly
going on and you know for example the
bladder cancers are mapping at various
different places as we add more examples
of different types of tumors we can get
a higher resolution on on the different
on the different possible connections
between these tumor types so I'm excited
that we're gonna find some interesting
things in this in this next six months
as we analyze this data in TCGA so this
is just to show you so you know I showed
you that like 1 in 10 tumors are sort of
mapping to places we didn't anticipate
like the bladder cancer example you know
even though 9 out of 10 did one out of
ten aren't and that's quite a quite a
number of people and I think in this in
this next map what you know that that
we've doubled we're getting more like
one in five so I think this is starting
to reach the point where it's gonna you
know be very very helpful for for the
use in precision medicine so as an
example so just remember this is just
using you know what
type of cancer you have what kind of
subtype so the idea here is to take this
map this reference map we have and then
take a new patients tumor and map it in
there and see if it tells us anything
interesting and we've embarked on this
at UCSC in this project we call tree
house and so the idea here is to take
data from children pediatric oncology
samples you know at this point that we
did it we only had a few of these cases
and you know usually they'll treat treat
the kids with heavy doses of radiation
and chemotherapy because I mean kids can
take it they're pretty hearty and they
usually respond but when they don't they
don't really you know there's there's
they're kind of at a loss for what to do
next there's not as much known about
pediatric cancer and so the idea was to
take the adult cancers from TCGA and
sort of use them as a backdrop of a
backdrop to look up the molecular
profiles of the kids cancers and see
what it tells us in collaboration with
these clinical trials and so the white
dots here are the places that these
these pediatric cancer samples mapped in
the pan can 33 map at the time showing
you some of the interesting cases you
know oftentimes we'll get you know a
tumor will map to an area where we
expected like a neuroblastoma we'll go
to a neuroblastoma and so forth or a
squamous cell carcinoma we'll go to the
squamous area but then there were some
cases like this sarcoma here that was
also mapping to a neuroblastoma and so
we had a few of these interesting cases
or this one was a neurofibroma that was
mapping to erbB driven breast cancer I'm
just gonna kind of skim through that one
so this case was followed up on a little
more so I wanted to focus the talk a
little bit on it the sarcoma that goes
in neuroblastoma is what we what we
noticed in that area in the network was
that that these neuroblastoma is the
grey hexagons all shared this ALK fusion
and so I could ALK fusions i first found
in lung
answers were shown to respond to this
drug Drew's at nib which is an ALK
inhibitor and then they subsequently
were able to use it for these
neuroblastomas where the neuroblastoma
has also had ALK fusion so we don't know
the fusion status for this particular
patient so but we could look up the ALK
expression level of ALK amplified tumors
and so forth and sort of compare the
expression level that we're seeing in
this in this patient sample and it was
an elevated level in this particular
sample it's at the it's at the level of
what you see in the ALK amplified or the
ALK fusion tumors and so the doctor
actually acted on this and gave the kid
crizotinib and the most of the met
shrunk not all of them and i it gave the
doctor a clue on on what next to do they
chose this alternative pathway jak-stat
to ALK they also gave them at this
jak-stat inhibitor so this just shows
you the diagram the alternative pathway
through jak-stat signaling that can
bypass ALK and a vision here's ALK so so
that and and then i it's so far you know
last report is that this patient is
doing well kind of using both the this
crizotinib and then alternating with
this jak-stat inhibitor so this is my
one example that i know so far where we
can take the this reference map look up
a particular you know n of one case and
where it's been followed up on and we've
we've now been invited to participate in
this california institute of precision
medicine to to expand on this and to try
this systematically instead of just ad
hoc like i showed you
so i mean now that we know that you know
the cancers come in these different
forms and if they reflect their their
their cells of origin and and and this
data is not only reflected by the the
the data types I showed you but also
people have shown that you know
mutations but that's both the number of
mutations and different tissues shown
along here the spectra like the type of
of particular variants that you have
have it have a certain reflect the
tumour of origin like here's your
melanomas up here with the UV signature
and so forth but more than that
if you look at the you know inside the
genomes at the EPI genomes and where the
mutations are lining up they tend to
line up in the you know you get more
mutations in the heterochromatin the
regions that are not as accessible in
this case by the DNA the DNA sends i'm
and and and folks have shown that it
correlates with the open closed
chromatin status which is sort of wired
into the the the normal tumor so this
was sort of an interesting result from
the Broad Institute part of the
epigenetics roadmap that came out where
you could see that if you if you look at
where the mutations are ganging up they
they reflect their to their tissue of
origin their normal tissue origin light
so the melanoma samples would would gang
up in the in the open in the close
domains of the the melanocytes and so
forth and pretty much without fail that
happened and then one of and one other
interesting result that they showed
which I'm not showing here is that if
you look at the domain structure of the
the tumors they don't correlate with
where the mutations are so it's the
normal cell state that predicts where
the mutations will will occur so again
that reflects the cell of origin and you
can you can further classify these
things that Lincoln's Stein and Katie
Hoadley have taken the results of the
whole genome analysis from ICGC and you
can sort of start classifying tumors
just based on on where these mutations
wind up in the genomes okay so so this
this shows this that we can that we can
you know sort of take datasets either
mutate
or expression data or methylation state
and sort of identify what what type of
cancer we have and so that that's that's
the first part of the story so the
second part is you know what do we do
with the you know the particular
oncogenic events that happen so you know
if you're looking for which mutation
there's passengers and drivers and we
want to figure out what one of the the
important mutations that that that have
you know in some patients sampling and
my group has worked on this but many
others have come before to work on
predicting drivers from passengers and
so forth to winnow down what are the
important ones so things in the that
that are sort of classic methods for in
inferring the importance of variants
like you sure many of you and some of
you worked on methods like this so look
at you know where the mutations happen
in the protein structure if it's in a
conserved area of the of the sequence to
figure out if it's important and these
are borrowed from you know germline
analysis but have carried over into
looking at somatic mutations as well you
can look at the frequency of these
events across a lot of different
patients you know more mutations may are
you know is it could be an indication
that it's a important event especially
if it there's recurrent events you know
the same exact position like in b-raf
you always have that v600e variant and
so forth and then whether it gangs up in
pathways so you know been Rafael's group
and and has pioneered some of this work
to look at how those mutations correlate
with with with known or predicted
pathways and seeing also whether genes
are in these mutual exclusive
relationships across patients since that
can also be a signature that they're
they're in the same pathway so the one
limitation is that these sort of predict
at the gene level which genes are
important which ones are getting mutated
right you want to know for a particular
patient okay they've got a
retinoblastoma or a p53 mutation is it
act is that it could be a DRI a
passenger event or but is there evidence
that it's actually important
patience tumor sometimes sometimes it is
and sometimes it isn't and so one method
that we've developed in the lab it's
called takes make takes advantage of our
pathway analysis that I didn't talk
about here that that's called paradigm
that sort of it will infer the
activities of a whole bunch of genes in
a pathway diagram that you give it from
integrated data but what the student did
was was take that those predictions and
then ask for a particular gene that
might be mutated we can look downstream
at the effects of in this particular
patient and see if if the pathway levels
look lower than what you expect from the
upstream regulators let's say so we kind
of do two types of pathway analysis one
where we disconnect the parents and one
where we disconnect the children and
then we look and see if the pathway
inferences give you a discrepancy for
this particular gene in this particular
patient and the student called this the
shift score so we call it paradigm shift
and we published quite a few different
uses of this and TCGA papers and so this
is an example of a of an example and an
oncogene where you can see that this
paradigm shift level by comparing the
upstream and the downstream levels would
expect to see that there's higher
activity downstream than you expect from
the regulator's and so it's inferring
this gain-of-function for the most part
in this in this particular gene and in
lung squamous cancers and so you could
go for forward and kind of run paradigm
shift on a whole bunch of of genes and
and then sort of implicate whether it's
active or inactive even if you have a
few number of examples that's sort of
the point of the red font here that we
don't need to look at recurrence or
frequency sort of gained power by
looking at the pathway neighborhood of
these things even in one particular
patient so there are other methods
coming out thankfully to try to help us
and for which which of these which which
of these events are are important you
can see we also ran this in several
different tumor types this is again n
feo to L to the mutate
Shen's are shown the mutated nfe2l2
tumors are right here in this little
section where where the black wedge is
right here and so you can see that it's
inferring gain-of-function for those
cases we've sorted this by tumor type
and you can see that there's other
examples where you know for example
where I'm pointing here where the method
inferred gain of activity and nfe2l2 but
there are no mutations and so one
interesting thing we did is we could we
sort of used this as a sieve to scan for
other events that correlate with that
prediction so what else may be causing
NF a tool to gain a function if it's not
an nfe2l2 mutation and so we could sort
of correlate all these other events with
that predicted activity and so what I'm
showing you here is this other mutation
a different gene keep one and that's an
example of a another gene that actually
interacts with nfe2l2 and that's sort of
the one of the most correlated
positively correlated events that's
going on in this in this pan-cancer data
set with nfe2l2 so we can use this to
sort of expand our knowledge find other
events that we may not know about that
that sort of correlate with with ones
that we do some yeah some of these do
like this one olfactory receptor and
well that's at some point we yeah
there's a cut-off that you have to
impose on the on the significance of
this so you know you know if either I'm
confident in NP one being anti
correlated with it or call three is
actually no one right yeah I mean we're
still working on you know where is this
thing and it's definitely worth
considering you know where to draw that
line and certainly olfactory receptors
are concerned so so turning toward what
we're gonna do about inferring this this
model for a patient right I've often
shown this sort of this cartoon
and and thankfully now we've embarked on
this and I get to show you some real
data that we've that we've had the
privilege of working on recently so if I
if I have the the set of mutations I
think are driving let's say are
important for a patient and again I we
have some representation of the subtype
of this patient then then the idea is to
try to fill in what is the the diagram
this this pathway model we could use to
think about what happened in this cancer
how to treat it and so forth so for the
first part we've sort of taken
inspiration from andreia Califano x'
group we can run you know their marina
analysis where you infer the
transcription factors that are activated
from gene expression signatures so once
you have a you know a particular subtype
of cancer may have a transcriptional
profile that that highly is is highly
predictive of that subtype then what we
do is we infer the transcription factors
or their combinations of transcription
factors that that seem to be driving
that tumor so that gets us you know up
one level and toward connecting up
things from the genomic mutations to the
to what we see sort of more
phenotypically at the expression level
and and and then so then we still have
to kind of kind of fill in this gap and
we took inspiration from again from Ben
Raphael's hotnet algorithm so we
published a method called tie-dye which
takes in different sets of data from a
particular patient or a subtype and it
builds a network that connects those
using network diffusion so if you have
two different sets you have here let's
say we have the mutations or other types
of alterations epigenetic or genetic and
then activated transcription factors
then you can use a diffusion process
that find those genes that interlink
those two sets and so we call these the
linker genes if they weren't in your
starting set and the tie dye network
sort of these combines both the the
things that you started with sources and
targets with those linkers and we've
shown that if you use these this just a
few
process we have multiple sets diffusion
and you look for their intersection that
you gain precision over finding actual
true linkages and networks compared to
some decoy links that we put in there
sorry to put hot note on on this con
this graph it's getting lower but it's
hot and it is sort of the single
diffusion approach there and we're
gaining the power by looking for the
intersection of sort of multiple hot net
processes when we use tie-dye so that
can get us sort of you know a way to
fill in the mutations to these activated
transcription factors and so our
question was whether this this this
reflected real biology these linker
genes and so we connected up with justin
drake and owen widdy's lab at UCLA so oh
and what he's an HHMI investigator UCLA
and they had collected a lot of
different phospho proteomic states for
8,000 of these peptides and in several
prostate cancer samples and so what we
could do is take data from four
mutations in these prostate cancer
samples and we could take the expression
data kind of build a network and then
asked whether the linker genes are can
are also found as activated kinase is in
these networks that we're looking at and
so if you if you build the tie-dye
network from from the the you know TCGA
expression data for these and from some
of the stand up to cancer patient data
that we had for metastatic versus versus
non metastatic disease and we'd see you
know this this enrichment for the linker
genes have a shift in activity right so
if you look up the the kinase activity
of the things that are linkers and
compare them to things that weren't
getting linked into the tie-dye networks
we see a good sign that that there's a
there's a there's a positive trend for
those things being included are actually
coming out in the in the in the in the
proteomic screen you can also kind of
ask the reverse you know if so we can
infer the activity of transcription
factors with things like Mirena
we could also infer
the activity of kinase is from from the
phospho proteomics data as well by using
you know Califano like method again
where instead of taking that the
transcription the transcription data and
looking at targets of transcription
factors we could take the proteomics
data and look at a kinase and ask is it
does the kinase seem to be getting
activated to this kind of an example if
you looked at the a Katie's levels right
so you know you can imagine looking at
all the phosphoprotein imax data and
seeing that okay this gene this kinase
here PR k ay-two is implicated because
because it many of its targets its act
that it's predicted to activate are also
phosphorylated and the ones that it's
supposed to not phosphorylate are also
not phosphorylated in the in the data
and so we see you know this is sort of a
slight enrichment 0.01 but we do see a
slight enrichment for you know the the
activated kinase is inferred from this
marina like method are nearby the
activated transcription factors in these
tie-dyes solutions right if you run it
many times with permutations on this
kind of thing or you compare it to a
background set then then we're seeing a
subtle enrichment here which is also
also good news okay so so what we can do
is what what our idea is we can take
since the proteomics data seems like
it's relating the expression data what
we can do is try to build an overall
Network from all this data using tie-dye
again where we give it mutations
expression proteomics and we can Bill
what we call the scaffold network for
metastatic prostate cancer and then it's
a huge network so you can kind of go
through and summarize what this network
looks like by looking at hallmarks and
their enrichment so this wheel just kind
of shows you what pathways are getting
bundled in with that I'm gonna kind of
speed up I guess I'm at a time here the
proteomics data is sort of enriches for
many different pathways over not using
it except for a couple here even though
we lost some enrichment here it still it
still is significantly enriched ok so
now that we have this scaffold Network
this just gives you an overview of some
of the
processing in here and we've seen
correlation with in Mets these genes
that are in these pathways are more
active than in non Mets just some
biological follow-up functional
follow-up on that
so finally now that we have a scaffold
network what we can do is we take an
individual patients
you know mutations and their data and
and then we take in the scaffold network
run tie-dye again to get sort of this
patient specific network and again you
can also look at the hallmarks of that
patient specific network this is sort of
what it looks like right you have a
pretty complicated overview a view of
this is for one particular patient
patient 40 so let me just maybe show an
example like if you hone in on those
things that relate to cell cycle you
know this this diagram tells you this
patient has a loss of heterozygosity and
a pap see like a deletion a mutation
that could impact the it also has an
amplification and these chromatin
remodelers chromatin remodeler and then
sorry that's a that's inferred the
amplification and an easy h2 on this
there these chromatin remodelers were
inferred to be activated and so forth
this is sort of what the diagram looks
like so to to cut to the chase you know
we've done this for several patients now
and we've had to think about well what
in those networks do you can you choose
as the targets and so we tried to
topologically sort these these
regulators that we're finding and this
is supposed to show you the tree it
didn't come all the way out but now we
have this diagram that we can kind of go
through and say well you could target
akt1 if it's activated or anything
underneath it's activated if you want to
if you think it's going to be then then
you might also target Sarek na KT and so
forth to try to cover most of this
network it's sort of a network cover
problem so that's sort of where we're at
now I'm at a time we're now actually
following up on some of the implicated
components of these networks to think
about combinations and testing those and
cell line models so the take-home
messages were you know we can find these
forms hopefully with with
cancer analysis there's some surprises
there about mapping to cross tumor
examples and this is set to increase
since where we've doubled the map I
showed you an example where the word
even helps you even that stage helps you
pick possible new treatment avenues for
the for pediatric cancers and finally
we're trying to put together these the
this you know it's a hierarchy of what
the target for a particular patient so
we can kind of come up with these
rational combinations so this is my my
group and that that did a lot of this
work and and it's also performed in the
context of the cancer genomics group run
by David Haussler and myself and and we
collaborate with with Chris Benz at the
buck so I will stop there I went a
minute over and I apologize thanks
yeah the tumor map I didn't say anything
about yeah each of those hexagons was a
tumor sample and they got positioned
based on similarity in in the underlying
data so if you compare their
transcriptomes
there's some similar to your correlation
and you can just do kind of these spring
embedding types of layouts in two
dimensions and then we just snap it to
this hexagonal grid and then we the the
browser that were set to publish on is
its we just use Google Maps and you can
load a bunch of data in there you can
browse it just like Google Maps sorry I
didn't say what the hell that was
question I have one yeah
well so yeah ultimately we're gonna have
well we my computational lab is not
gonna sit sit down and say you know
treat this and then that you know what
we want to do is bring this information
to the tumor board meeting
you know the there'll be other so you
know it'll be one of the things brought
up when they do the the genomics workup
of that tumor right we can say you know
the pathway results indicate you could
treat this patient with you know Sark
right like so if your I showed you guys
patient forty I guess right they have
activated a KT or predicted a PDC so you
if you've got and some of these have
drugs known for them so we could treat
with this a KT inhibitor and if we were
worried about you know check to get also
you know getting turned on we could pick
either cdk1 or a Sark in combination
with that this so I'm hoping we have
some kind of diagram like this that
could be helpful for reasoning through
the combinations that you could use
the same question so it is two more
board meeting is is the computational
representative yeah yeah there so there
we get what basically one person that is
the that is the consultant from the
computational workup of this thing but
they're also there with the you know the
clinical researcher that we collaborate
with to help us sort of translate our
findings to make it understandable to
the to the doctors definitely one
question about that turn the marina
analysis no so what what is this game
for you question it does yeah I think it
you know the we you've got this big
transcriptional profile and it does
reduce the dimensionality I think
probably in a in a useful way it's
probably not the best way to do it but
it's probably helping to clean up some
of the noise that that's in there and
and honing in on some dominant signal
maybe it helps you get at the the major
subclone I don't I'm not sure why you
know why it helps other you know fern
right now it is sort of a mathematical
convenience that we're using it just to
summarize the transcriptional data but I
think that's a good question and and
possibly a limitation because it does it
rely on target
somewhat not not fully I mean you can
you can kind of give it a regula and it
can get it can infer regulan a little
bit as well by looking at correlated
activities of predictive some other
targets it can kind of pull it into
their to the regulan but yeah it is it
is biased by a known biology thank you